Robert F Kennedy Jr thanks for talking
to reason
thanks for having me okay so Joe Biden
currently has an approval rating that's
in the low 40s he is it is you know
basically the same that Donald Trump a
one-term president had at this same
point what is in his first uh possibly
only term what is Joe Biden doing wrong
and how would a Robert F Kennedy Jr
presidency address those main problems
and make things better
well I would start out with uh the
conduct of the war we now know that in
April of uh
201 that
um at the it was at zielinski and and
Putin essentially had a peace treaty
that they had signed
and that uh
Boris Johnson was sent over there almost
certainly at the past of the White House
to disrupt that treaty and I you know
that's not the only time that we've had
opportunities for peace
Accords also were an opportunity that we
lost for peace that the Russians had
agreed to sign that
French and Germans had agreed to the
zielinski campaigned in 2019 on that he
would sign it and and something made him
pivot
and the assumption is once he got in
there
he won 70 percent of the vote by running
as a peace candidate
and then something uh something changed
his mind the assumption is that it was a
threats against his life
a right-wing nationalist within Ukraine
and the intervention of Victoria Newland
and other people on the U.S side who
wanted at war with Russia
everything we've done every decision
we've been told this is a humanitarian
crisis uh which is which would would
indicate we should shorten the war
and reduce the Bloodshed but every
decision that we've made including the
decision to refuse to meet with any
Russian counterparts do you think uh do
you think Biden is actively trying to
extend the war because it fits with his
worldview or is he just incompetent at
you know basic diplomacy well I don't
know I don't know I think he's
surrounded by people who have wanted
this or for a long time
and that uh Joe Biden has is a you know
has been a figure
has had a career of being a uh a
spokesperson for warhawks for the
neocons and for the other kind of those
uh parts of the federal government that
are
um you know of the state department the
CIA the intelligence apparatus
and the White House particularly the
neocons like Victoria Lynn Robert Kate
and those
uh who are pro or he was
for example during the Iraq War roll-up
he was one of the he was he was leading
the Democrats my uncle was aligned
against and my uncle was very close to
Biden
uh but was very very much against his
pro-war policy and
Biden has always been like that are you
um you know uh Biden did get us out of
Afghanistan was was that the right move
at the right time yeah I mean yes it was
the right move to get us out of
Afghanistan
um you know reasons audiences is largely
made up of Libertarians we believe in
free minds and free markets in limiting
government and increasing individual
autonomy as you're running for president
and you're you're pulling you know 15 18
in various polls what is a message to
Libertarians who believe in you know
free minds and free markets that you can
bring to them
well I think I'm aligned I've always
been aligned with Libertarians on
on most issues I mean there's tweaks
that I have
um you know that as an environmentalists
I don't think uh I don't think
libertarianism works well in the Commons
at least in any way that's practical
uh but I but when it you know and those
are those are
policy those are assets that are not
susceptible to private property
ownership like the shared assets of our
community what we call the public trust
assets or the the commons or the
Commonwealth
uh the air the water the wildlife
Fisheries public lands uh aquifers those
kind of things that you do need
government regulation
um because
of a
um an economic law called tragedy of the
commons which which which
suggests that all of us will catch the
last fish in the ocean but doesn't that
also imply that we should be privatizing
more of the commons because when you
have clear property rights you tend to
take better care of them than if they're
left
I I you know I've seen schemes like that
you know particularly regulation of
Fisheries that have worked well in some
cases but
there's something really undemocratic
about it I mean what you know one of the
reasons that we that a British you know
rose up and fought the Battle of running
meat was because King John tried to
privatize the you know the rivers of
England the Thames and erect tolls on
the Thames
he privatized uh you know the game
animals the fish and the hair which is
about a problem with Robin Hood he
privatized the fisheries and those
those assets were social safety net so
if you're a farmer and you're corrupt
didn't come in you could go down to the
Thames and you could pull out a fish and
you could feed your family even go into
the forest
and kill a deer and uh and you know
there's something very Democratic in
fact the magnet the full uh name of the
bad part is that a charter of the forest
uh because it it recognized that the
commons belonged to all of us that
whether you're rich or poor humble or
Noble
acry white European or you know African
or wherever your Origins if you were a
citizen
that you had an equal right to cross
over a beach and pull out your fish
the emperor himself couldn't stop you
and if you start privatizing that
resources it takes the the asset away
from the poor
yeah I I agree I mean I I don't think I
don't know anybody who uh you know wants
to bring back capital punishment for
poaching and you know Federal lands and
things like that but there are ways to
either uh create private property rights
or transferable rights that lead to
Surplus right so
um but I you know thank you for uh you
know going directly at a at a point
where there's probably some distance uh
let's do a lightning round we're going
to come back to questions like
environmentalism and covet policy and
foreign policy uh in depth in a bit but
let's do a lightning round if you were
elected president
um name some of the people that you
expect or you would like to appoint as
Secretary of State who do you who for
you would be a great secretary of state
of mind
I think I can answer that question
because
I um
I don't really want to Telegraph my
choices like that I mean you know I love
uh I love Tulsi gabbard I like her that
you know she understands the you know
the importance of
um of of
disentangling of unraveling the Empire
and unraveling the War Machine
and I would who is the last great
secretary of state
um do you think that we have
uh um
well I mean there's secretaries have
stayed in the past that I liked and I
don't like everything they did you know
it's like presidents I mean I you know
uh was you know Dean ages and a good
Diplomat yeah I didn't give my uncle
good advice on
Cuban Missile Crisis no yeah I mean I I
I you know tell me it tell me a
secretary of state and I'll tell you
what I like about him and what I didn't
like you know fair enough fair enough in
it I know you've spoken highly of
Eisenhower's military industrial complex
speech in his his farewell speech but
I'm sure you don't agree with everything
that Eisenhower stood for oh and you
know that was you know I'll say this
about Eisenhower that
Eisenhower I think really did try to
disentangle you know he was very very
worried and he did think for example
he was trying to make peas with with
Russia he was trying to develop the same
relationship with Khrushchev that my my
uncle ultimately did
and you know he was going to have these
Summits in Geneva to try to end the Cold
War
and and create the taunt but and those
were disrupted by the CIA you know by
the U2 flight that was then shot down
with Gary Powers in it
and that's something that had to be
canceled and then of course Dulles got
Eisenhower to lie about you know the
YouTube flights when when they didn't
know that the Russians had captured Gary
Powers and then when they you know they
produced them
it was a huge embarrassment to
Eisenhower in the whole Geneva process
fell apart but I do think Eisenhower
intended well
you know and and Eisenhower another
interesting thing about Eisenhower is he
said
it will never be a veteran soldier who
gets us into the next War you know and
he was speaking basically of my uncle
when he said that but he had been to war
Cruze of it than to work his Khrushchev
was in the most
violent battle of World War II which was
Stalingrad the worst battle of World War
II I think by anybody's estimation and
he did not want to go back to that place
again he did not so is it is it that
Putin was not a soldier Putin was an
intelligence guy so kind of like Nixon
or LBJ yeah he'll get us into an export
well yeah I don't know I I'm not
convinced Putin wanted a war oh I you
know I'm
I think the jury is still out on that I
think that we could have avoided the War
I think we did a series of provocations
that um that you know and this isn't
just me saying this
you know speaking of great diplomats
George Cannon who was you know probably
the greatest Diplomat in American
history was the architect of the
contentment policy during the Cold War
in 1992 James Baker agreed that we would
not move an 801 inch to the East and the
the the concession for that agreement
that the German that we
Russians had made was the Russians have
had agreed to move
400 000 troops out of East Germany and
allow us to consolidate both Germany's
under NATO which was a foreign enemy an
adversarial Army and the Russians said
Gorbachev said I'll move them out but
you have to promise you're not going to
move NATO to the east after I do that
Secretary of State
under Bush famously said we will not
move Nato one inch to the east
and in 1997 but that I mean let's uh
this is a lightning round I I understand
your argument about that there's you
know uh you know there's America is
never blameless but you are also not the
ones Crossing Borders right now um can I
ask
um would you ban gas stoves uh in this
the lightning round we'll come back to
these in depth if you would like you
know people are talking about banning
Subs the Biden Administration is about
talking about banning gas stoves yes or
no yeah
I would not bad gas stoves great uh
would you ban the use of Roundup
herbicide
uh would I ban it I would
certainly make them uh label it and I
would do it yeah everything I could
could to make sure that Monsanto is
honest about the injuries that it causes
that people are buying Now with an open
you know and with an arm arm's life
negotiation understanding that they're
buying something that's deadly poisonous
okay uh would you ban would you ban any
would you ban any major prescription or
over-the-counter drugs that are now on
the market
uh
comes to mind at the moment but you know
would you uh you uh have a personal
history of of substance abuse your
family has uh you know certain recurring
motifs along that would you legalize
drugs or or what currently illegal drugs
would you legalize
I would I would decriminalize marijuana
on a federal basis and allow the states
to regulate it
well I would have a federal tax on it
though and I would
apply that tax building rehabilitation
centers around the country and providing
people re you know drug rehabilitation
uh what about psychedelics which have
been uh decriminalized at the state
level in Oregon in Colorado definitely
decriminated Alex okay uh would you
support immigration reforms that make it
easier for more people to come here and
live and work legally in America yes I
would okay uh would make it impossible
for people to
cross supporter illegally and I would
open up immigration for legal
immigration
would you ban uh so-called assault
weapons
oh I'm not going to take away anybody's
guns hey do if if
if there wasn't consensus where
Republicans and Democrats voted a
majority to do that I would sign the
bill
great uh would you pardon Ross Albrecht
the founder of the Silk Road the uh Deep
Web uh drug Market Julian Assange of
WikiLeaks or Edward Snowden
I would pardon us on
immediately because he's a newspaper
publisher and it is crazy uh it's crazy
what they're trying to do to him it's
completely Manny American I would Pop I
would pardon Snowden because
what's noted for the American people was
to you know help restore at least some
semblance of democracy and the
importance of the of them
information he released
was so it's so it's a tested to the fact
that Congress passed legislation uh
recognizing you know the disclosures
that he had and making sure that you
know to try to make sure that those kind
of abuses didn't occur again so I think
he is a hero not uh it shouldn't be
treated as a villain
um with Ross Albrecht I I you know I
need to
I I need to look into that my my
understanding of Ross Albrecht the way
that I understand it now is that he was
uh you know is given two life terms
for something that normally you would
not be given that and if I investigate
this which I'm going to do very very
quickly
and I find out that he was not being
punished so much for his crimes but
being punished as an example to teach a
lesson or to uh you know to
uh to increase the bias against uh
against you know Bitcoin and I will
release him
great thank you yeah thank you thank you
for uh working through that rapid fire
battery of questions it helps us get a
sense of where you're coming from on a
bunch of issues and now we'd like to dig
deeper into some of those issues I'm
sure there's a lot there that much many
in our audience will like some that they
won't like I appreciate that you opened
with a discussion of foreign policy and
kind of singling that out is your reason
for challenging Biden in the primary
because foreign policy tends to be
Central for many Libertarians on
deciding the presidency so what I'm
curious about is you laid out some of
your critique of Biden's approach to
Ukraine the people who surrounded
himself with but what is the RFK Junior
Doctrine for the proper use of military
force or military assistance that's easy
it has to be in the U.S national
interests
and what's going on in Ukraine is not in
the U.S national interest
S no I mean I think it's against the U.S
national interest and I also think it's
against the Ukrainian actual interest I
think Ukraine is uh is you know a victim
here of not only Putin but of U.S
policies of
is I think there are people in the U.S
government that want it to make Ukraine
a you know a pawn and a proxy war a U.S
proxy or against Russia and we've been
very clear about that I mean that you
know they have not been ambiguous
President Biden themselves at the
purpose of the words to depose Vladimir
Putin
which is uh what would be the last war
um when you say you know a war has we
would only fight Wars that are in the
National interest what's the last war
that was actually in the U.S interest do
you think well you know I I would say
all right World War II very it was
definitely a interest I I'm gonna
I'm gonna hold off at the discussion on
Korea
um I I I would say World War II
definitely was and perhaps Korea
you know you said that the objective
here is to overturn uh Putin's regime
um and what we've just seen unfold in
Russia is that their mercenary Force
just marched to just over 100 miles
outside Moscow before backing off and
Russia looks a lot weaker right now than
much of the world might have expected
what do you say to Americans who look at
what's happening and think well maybe
Biden's approach is actually working to
achieve his objectives
and what's the objective is the
objective deposed Vladimir Putin and is
that something we really want right now
do we know who's going to replace him
or is this like Saddam Hussein will you
identified somebody that we don't like
we get rid of them and then you know all
hell breaks us and and you're now
dealing with a nation which you know
where Bruton is very very popular
there's something extremely popular
leader
it's a nation that controls more nuclear
weapons than we own
and it's very important to us to have
somebody who we know
who we can predict who is uh who is able
to maintain stability in that Nation
and if you do replace Putin are you
going to re replace them with somebody
who uh who is more or less likely to let
those nuclear weapons get out of control
that's you know that's what we should be
thinking about here do we really know
how popular or unpopular or Putin is I
mean there's
um you know what is unfolded Putin you
know did initiate the invasion of
Ukraine and there seems to have been
some number of anti-war protests within
Russia there's lots of stuff that's it's
hard to interpret exactly what's coming
out of there there seem to be some
support on the ground for what the
Wagner group was doing
um some support for you know to the
degree they were seen as trying to bring
this war conflict to an end
um you know revolutions happen within
countries even without the US you know
putting their foot on the gas or pouring
gasoline on the fire so how do we decide
you know what it is like how do you
interpret those Events first of all let
me ask your question is there's there
are lots and lots of of public opinion
polls in Russia and those public opinion
polls indicate
that Putin is popular that the um that
the that the people of Russia generally
don't know of course not 100 percent
support the uh the war in Ukraine and I
you know I you're putting me in a
position where I'm sounding like an
apologist for Putin and I I'm not I like
Vladimir Putin right
right and I and his war in the Ukraine
was illegal and it was brutal and it was
unnecessary he had other options
uh but you know I do think that people
in the United States should uh that we
need to understand our role in in us in
a series in a decade of provocations
that put the Russians in that position
and as I said it's our Premier diplomats
like George Cannon
like William Perry who threatened to
resign as Clinton's
uh Secretary of Defense if we continue
to move NATO to the east like Bill Burns
who was then the Soviet the U.S
ambassador Soviet Union who also said if
we continue to move it to the east
we are going to provoke the Russians
into a violent response it will be
beyond their uh capacity to do anything
else so you know they we were warned do
not do this
there was no reason for us to do it we
won the Cold War we should have treated
Russia differently but we continue to
treat them as anatomy and continue to
encircle them now what about what about
China you said something else
you said at the you at least I believe
what you were suggesting and the the
Wagner group
uh invasion of Russia had something to
do with a protest against the war and my
understanding of that which I think is
pretty well informed
was acting out of self-interest because
because the change status of the Lucas
which are now part of Russia under the
Russian Constitution it was illegal for
for uh unincorporated mercenary group
to be operating on Russian soil so the
Russian government the Russian
Federation said we've got to incorporate
our group in the Russian army the people
who are profiting enormously like
pregosian from the Wagner group did not
want it Incorporated and it was a
dispute over self-interest and and you
know the reaction
of the Russian people origin was a very
very popular figure in Russia I do not
think he is anymore
can you clarify real quick what I was
saying and then I'll let Nick move us
onto the the next topic here but um it
was that the statements being put out by
pregosia and were that you know uh the
the defense Ministry and Putin have been
executing this war poorly and that at
least the imagery coming out on the
ground was that they were being
celebrated by the people in the town
they had occupied There Was You Know
images of even like flowers being
stuffed into cannons and stuff like this
we don't know you know you don't know
how to interpret any of that any of this
could be propaganda but
um that that's what I was getting at
with the idea that there's perhaps a war
weariness and kind of dissatisfaction
with how things have actually played out
in Russia I I I believe
that father has been critical of the
Russian of the war from the
beginning but not because
they object to the war in Ukraine they
what they were objecting to is that the
right of the Russian government was not
Conquering the Ukraine uh in a way that
was a fish and you know literally smart
it wasn't because they didn't like the
war it was you know found their group
was the front line of that war from the
beginning from beginning of the Crimea
yes
I don't think you know and and by the
way 80 percent
of a group stayed in their barracks
there's only 4 000 troops that went
along with this game and the indication
are that most of them did not know what
they were doing
that they were you know that they were
lied to by precaution
so I don't think I think it's hard to
read and by the way
the you know the the Russian front lines
in uh Ukraine that did not show any
weakness
oh you know there's uh this is if this
were really weakening Raja you would see
that you know Ukraine doing it offensive
right now and you're not seeing that
you're not seeing any faltering on the
Russian line so I don't know I think
or the Glee and the American Press
there's you know all this in this
Orthodoxy that it's not well informed
and I again I I wanted to I mean there's
something something has been shown here
uh geopolitically and again this is less
to do with America uh American
intervention although you've been I
think rightly critical of a blank check
style of support to Ukraine the fact
that Russia could not you know actually
uh occupy Ukraine is a sign that it's
kind of a paper tiger right
well I mean I guess we're a paper tiger
too because absolutely we I mean this is
you know right it's hard 21st century
has not been good to Global superpowers
right oh I mean it's harder than people
thought it would be to occupy countries
that don't want to be occupied like
Afghanistan like Iraq
yeah like amen like Syria you know and
all the other places that we have you
know Illustrated our paper tigerism over
the past two decades
um you know one place or Vietnam for
that for that matter yeah uh one place
of uh General agreement between a lot of
your statements and I think Libertarians
have to do with um uh you know the
entwining of social media platforms you
know Twitter Facebook Instagram and uh
the government to suppress certain types
of voices certain types of uh
information uh disinformation
misinformation Mal information in the
name of Public Health and whatnot how
would you deal with such issues
um is there something fundamentally
rotten about the way that social media
platforms have acted over the past you
know 10 years or so and how do you
address that well you know what
it's a good question what we you know
what we saw what we've seen is this
cooperate the disturbing thing
is the cooperation between government
and the social media side
and suppressing to sign against
government policy so that
seems to be a direct violation of the
First Amendment
um and normally you would say okay the
social media sites are private companies
and that means they're an analogous to
publishers
and a publisher can publish anybody they
want they can de-platform anybody they
want but now there's another issue here
which is these platforms are now
are so dominant of the public discourse
that they have become the Public Square
so the question is should they be
regulated like common carriers because
in order to protect democracy and
conversation debate discourse
and that's an issue that's kind of the
ultimate nuclear option I think for
foreign do you think that they should be
well I don't know but I I think that I
think that they should be
have a special responsibility I would
rather see it uh continue in private ads
but I think they have a special
responsibility to avoid
um cooperation with the government so
does that mean you know uh uh you're
asking me what I would do and let me be
very brief about that
I think it's a problem that everybody
recognized I think more and more we're
seeing that the with the exception of
Google perhaps which is continuing to
censor people on YouTube in a way that's
really outrageous
I think Twitter and I you know in
Zuckerberg
the indications are they did not want to
they were resentful at the uh what was
being demanded of the government they're
in a weak position because they have
contracts with the government and
they're just weak as we're seeing in
Europe today because the European Union
is now getting up to censor people
outright
what I would do what I'm gonna do
is I'm going to get them all to come to
the White House and I'm going to sit
down on them and say how do you want to
do this how here are the values that we
share
which is these should be open platforms
and you know they're very important to
American American democracy
what do we need to do to protect them
and what are you willing to do you know
because and if you don't have a plan for
that then you know I think we have to
start thinking of of regulating them as
common carriers yeah you know I
um
think that it was a big mistake of the
tech companies to capitulate to this
kind of backdoor job owning that was
going on that we've talked about on the
stream I don't think that people like
you should have been continually
de-platformed even though we've got some
areas of I think acute disagreement that
we'll get into in a little bit what I
worry about with overarching uh even
like the threat of like we're going to
now regulate you like common carriers is
that it prevents the exactly the kind of
innovation and social media that solves
a lot of these problems I mean we've
seen so many platforms proliferate in
response to these problems now and it's
like whenever there's some sort of
federal uh regulation like that it
becomes that only the multi-billion
dollar companies are really capable of
complying with those kind of regulations
how do you
think about or cope with that problem
that seems to occur in lots of sectors
of the economy
what you're saying to me is
that if there's Federal Regulation of
the kind that I'm talking about
cooperation that it will benefit these
you know these existing monopolies
I I I'm sensitive to that you know I I
would listen to those arguments
my objective is to have
untethered speech you know and and their
speech that's not protected
shouting fire and it crowded there is
not protected within the number of the
of the First Amendment or is pedophilia
or advocating violence or you know a lot
of other kinds of vehicles or fraud for
example but
if it's protective speech it should be
untethered even if it speaks I don't
like
and my objective is how do we create a
platform hopefully within a free market
system
that
um that will do that will serve that
function
do you like the types of laws that uh
you know conservative legislatures in
Florida and Texas these laws have been
signed by Greg Abbott in Texas and uh
Ron DeSantis in Florida that essentially
said that social media platforms or
internet companies above a certain size
have to uh they cannot de-platform
certain types of users uh political
candidates and things like that and if
they do they will face court fines these
these have been held up in you know by
the uh courts but do you support that
kind of regulation of social media
speech yeah I do okay and what about
hate speech because that tends to be a
right-wing solution to a perception that
conservatives are being unfairly bumped
you know from these platforms are
limited uh are having their reach uh
squelch uh on the left you hear a lot of
people talking about trying to ban hate
speech um is hate speech a meaningful
category to you and is it something the
problem of that the problem with that is
that the interpretation of what's hate
speech is uh utterly a objective
um subjective
so uh it leaves in the hands you know it
puts in the hands of of
authority figures presumably government
officials you know the capacity to
regulate all speech and you know my
speech was called hate speech the DHS
still classifies a criticism of vaccines
as a form of hate speech or terrorism
and uh and then you know so that's not a
good result because so I I say I'm very
you know of course I don't like hate
speech but
no in 1977 the Liberals in this country
are Consolidated behind the you know the
idea that we needed to protect the Nazis
who were marching through Skokie
Illinois through a Jewish neighborhood
and everybody was appalled by what they
were doing but you know everybody
understood that we have to we we have to
fight to protect the right for free
speech even when that speech is utterly
repugnant to us
um speaking of free speech uh in the
past you have called for the jailing of
CEOs and climate change Skeptics we've
got a clip from 2014 of you
um let's run that clip and then could
you explain what was your thinking and
whether or not it's changed since then
sure be in jail I think they should be
enjoying three Hots and a cot at the hay
with all the other war criminals who are
there what about politicians uh people
who deny who expressed septicism they're
selling out the public trust and you
know I think those guys who are doing a
Koch brothers bidding and who are
against all the evidence of the rational
mind
are saying that global warming doesn't
exist that they are contemptible human
beings and that you know I wish that
there were a law you could punish them
under
I don't think there's a lot of you can
punish those politicians under but I do
I think the Koch brothers should be
prosecuted for reckless and dangerous
absolutely that's a criminal offense and
they ought to be serving time for it
all right well thank you very much
appreciate it
okay
um do you still feel that way obviously
we're down one Coke brothers yeah you
know
um you have to look at the the earlier
part of that clip which he didn't show
okay it shows I was being asked a
question about their criminal uh conduct
the coke energy at that time was I think
it was the third or fourth largest air
polluter in the world
it was maintaining Petco piles in
Detroit and Chicago that were poisoning
poor neighborhoods it was it was the the
uh it had been criminally convicted of
violating Inferno which means it did it
knowingly in order to make money
and what I say earlier on the clip I say
if I you know a black kid
was ten dollars from a grocery store you
go to jail but why shouldn't the Koch
brothers be going to jail
do you think people who because
I do I I have said
that um at companies that certain
certain or certain uh entities corporate
entities
that habitually violate the law or whose
purpose is they injure the public
um uh public wheel the public interest
those corporations should be subject to
the corporate death penalty
and what that means is there's a there's
a um you know the corporations are
licensed by the states but most of the
state's requirements that the
corporation in order to get a charter
and it operate in the public interest
and if it departs from the public
interest in other words if it's
completely consumed by private interest
that is actually damaging the public
interest in the states
the Secretary of State
and the Attorney General have the
capacity in various States
that Charter in every state you know
somebody has the ability to yank that
Charter for example in New York state
in the 1990s
um the Republican attorney general uh uh
liquidated the tobacco Institute
the tobacco Institute was an Institute
that was created by the tobacco by
Philip Morris and the other tobacco
companies
those companies knew for 60 years that
their product was killing one out of
every four of their customers who use
the product as directed but they were
aligned to the public benefit they were
creating hey let me finish this because
this is important for people to know you
know because I've been accused of this
before
they were the tobacco Institute was
created
to deceive the public about the danger
of tobacco and it was it was given the
corporate death penalty in New York and
its assets were then distributed
uh the Koch brothers at that time were
funding a series of think tanks that
were designed to hide pollution to
minimize pollution to do things that
were
um that were dangerous to the public and
that were fraudulent do you think that's
still the case the First Amendment does
not protect the First Amendment does not
protect fraudulent speech if you're if
you say something that is fraudulent
you're not protected so and I do believe
that people who do that should be
punished now
at the time I made that
the Exxon Corporation had secret
documents which we had obtained
that showed that excellent scientists
have been informing the company that
they're scientists and more Brad poses
if they knew more about the fate of the
carbon molecule
and any other scientist in the world and
those scientists that concluded that
global warming was real that it was
going to destroy the Arctic melt the
Arctic and they wrote memos to the uh to
the senior staff
at Exxon saying we if we keep doing what
we're doing we are going to melt the
Arctic and that will be a bad thing for
Humanity it will be a good thing for our
company because there's a lot of oil
under the art and we can get at it
so that was the information that I was
dealing with at that time and you know
which was almost a perfect analogy for
what the tobacco Institute so I mean but
do you think that you know do you think
that uh you know organizations that
received funding from uh you know the
Koch brother at this point should be uh
should be given the corporate death
penalty no okay okay
and is it is it any less chilling of
speech you know you were talking about
back then I didn't believe that I
believe that well you just said that you
were that
that it's the same thing as the tobacco
Institute so yeah
even if they if they were given
if they if they're if the organization
if the purpose that organization was to
deceive the public
and and yeah they should uh did we want
to I mean I I guess just you know on
this question of free speech uh you know
do we want people in positions of power
to be deciding what is acceptable speech
that this is misinformation or mal
information or disinformation
um it just seems like that way Madness
lies because the government will always
come up with a pretext for saying your
speech is not just wrong it's criminal
and you need to be shut down
but I do believe that prosecutors
and judges make decision about what's
fraud all the time and you know we and
we want to preserve that and nobody ever
says that that is a uh you know that
that's an inhibition of free speech you
know what when I say what I see when I
look at that clip and think of the
debate especially in the 2010s around
climate change as I see a lot of
parallels with the kova debate in the
2020s because both climate change and
covid are real and they carry risks to
humans but the reality of those risks
and trade-offs can be more nuanced than
just saying you know just trust the
science or the science is settled and a
lot of those who wanted to have a debate
over the policy agenda embedded in the
climate change discourse or the covid
discourse or suppressed de-platformed
called deniers even called to be
criminalized or asked that I wish there
were laws to Criminal realize this kind
of speech do you regret partaking in
that kind of discourse after kind of
going through this in the covet era yeah
you make a good point and having seen
what happened ever
if I had known that back then I I
probably would not have made that speech
and also I I see or you know made that
statement
um but I also seen you know in recent
years how you know how the crises of
coven was manipulated and uh and
exploited
by powerful interest to clap down
totalitarian controls and to
um and to you know impose uh
Technologies on people that uh that were
making them profits
for which they on the IPS and I'm seeing
a lot of that now with uh in the carbon
area I'm seeing you know his emphasis on
geoengineering which I think is very
damaging the environment I'm seeing
what's happening to the whales off the
east coast of North America
um and you know something that I thought
very long for 30 years of putting those
uh wind turbines out there we have a lot
of wind on land in this country
and we shouldn't be turning the oceans
into industrialized Zone isn't
destroying whales
oh there's a lot of things that I know
now that I you know that I think the
issue is more complex today than it
seemingly was at that point before let's
let's turn to covet and vaccines but
just to close out a discussion of
environmental issues you seem to have uh
recently uh in a in a Twitter space
discussion with Elon Musk you've
signaled that you would be open to
nuclear power under certain
circumstances in a in a way that you are
emphatically anti-nuke uh you know a
couple of decades ago is that accurate
uh or what are the conditions that you
would put upon nuclear energy before you
would allow that to go forward since we
know that is a zero carbon uh you know
kind of uh fix to uh the world that
we're in
always said about who can I think I've
said this for at least 30 years
is that I'm all for it if you can make
it safe and if you can make it uh
economically competitive then right now
you know I have not seen anything that
indicates that either of those are true
about nuclear power
how do you how do you measure that
though because you know what I've read
is that more people were killed in
Fukushima uh you know being evacuated
than died from anything related to
radiation
that is a popular industry talking
pointless I have the same stuff about
your Noble but
to answer the UN did say I mean after
you know the the death count and even
the environmental damage from Chernobyl
was you know not what anybody expected
and oil and gas I mean all energy
production
we don't need to argue about this you
know the the estimates of Chernobyl go
from
I think three or four five thousand add
to five million dead so depending on who
I believe but I personally have visited
a uh a community a very very large
community of thousands of children
in Cuba who were damaged who were you
know who were injured and ultimately
most of them killed by uh uh because of
Chernobyl so and that you know
I guess it let me ask your question okay
because it's the easy answer that we
don't have to
litigate this issue the answer is
as soon as they get an insurance policy
oh the insurance industry is the
ultimate Arbiter of risk
and the and that nuclear industry cannot
get an insurance policy so I mean there
is no I mean nuclear energy in America
from you know after World War II was
folded into defense things and it's it's
run by the government there's like not
an energy sector that is more regulated
by you know Federal uh and state and
local red tape us I don't know that
that's asked me a question yeah the
question is how do I know it's not safe
yeah and and I'll talk about efficiency
and economy okay the answer is it safe
my word about whether it's safe or not
is meaningless and as we've just seen
litigated here's the here's the answer
they can't get an insurance policy if
they could get there's no insurance
company in the world
I will write them a policy so they had
to go to Congress in a sleazy
legislative maneuver in the middle of
the night and get the price Anderson Act
pass
which gives them immunity from liability
there's the same as the vaccine industry
just to close this out and let's go to
vaccines but I mean you're also talking
about a massive amount of beachfront
property in America that wouldn't be you
know wouldn't be possible without all
sorts of government interventions into
Insurance markets Insurance markets are
not free markets so I don't I don't
think we can conclude this but if you're
if you're conducting if you're like for
example a vaccine company and you say I
can't operate
unless you free me from liability you
know that is an indication that what
you're doing is not safe and all you
know it's AIG now let me just answer the
second question I'll be very quick
the the nuclear the last nuclear plant
built cost 14 billion dollars a gigawatt
Capital expenses
oh and a solar plant costs one billion
when plant costs about 1.1 1.28 billion
a uh a coal plant costs 3.6 billion a
gigabyte
we could make energy by burning prime
rib if we wanted but why would you use
the most expensive and then
you've got to mine the uranium which is
not carbon free and it is very very in
areas of the environment and then you've
got a higher technicians you have to
have all of these scheduled maintenance
outages which is very expensive
then you have to store the ways for the
next 30 000 years which is five times
the length of recorded human history
right and if you were if they and every
every form of energy production has
environmental overflows as well as I
believe in free markets and it had a
Marketplace
would you I guess just to close this out
would you also I mean if you want a free
market in this would you get rid of all
subsidies for uh renewable energy at
this point I would get rid of subsidies
for all energy they're the biggest most
highly subsidized energy is carbon much
more than solar wind there's 5.2
trillion dollars a year in subsidies for
carbon okay we're all alone in this
country alone gets 1.2 trillion a year
if you ended that you know Carmen could
not survive in a Marketplace okay great
let's talk let's talk about something
less contentious which is uh covid and
vaccines and obviously you have hit a
nerve because of what's unfolded during
the covid years and you know it was
something that I was disturbed by a lot
of covet policy including the
implementation and mandating of the
vaccines although not necessarily their
creation
um I also think vaccines on net save a
lot of lives whether we are talking
about the coveted vaccine or something
like measles which I'm just gonna pull
this slide up real quick this is showing
the measles vaccine being licensed in
1963 all these sources will be in our
description and on our web page but then
you see after the licensure the measles
cases drastically decline it was
basically eliminated by in the U.S by
the year 2000 and then started coming
back as people got complacent stopped
vaccinating so much uh and then by 2019
there were up to a thousand uh over a
thousand cases and these outbreaks
occurred in places where
unsurprisingly under vaccinated
communities communities that objected to
the vaccines for religious reasons and
so forth or political reasons so that is
that is my concern it's that
um I you know I think some of your
critiques of what happened during the
coveted years are totally legitimate but
I worry that your rise in elevation is
going to possibly accelerate the return
of more diseases that heretofore have
been eradicated what do you say to an
independent voter like me who's in that
mindset and who is voted for Republicans
were voted for Democrats voted for
Libertarians before but has this you
know concern hanging over my head
yeah I mean my I'm not there any vaccine
I never have been if you show me a
vaccine that works and that makes people
healthier
the MMR vaccines don't work well I would
like to see data that show that people
I would like to see a vaccinated versus
unvaccinated study that show that people
who get the MMR vaccine are in uh are
healthier
uh a decade later how do you explain
this graph you know you said many things
that are you know a part of the kind of
industry propaganda
what is that a vaccine that you know
those later Rises
and vaccination in uh in measles come
from unvaccinated individuals that come
from the you know the complacency but
vaccine vaccination rates have gone up
continuously there's no time in our
country
of vaccination rates have dwindled have
gone lower so they they continue to go
so there's not a time when they went
lower than those that suddenly you see
about you can look at isolated
communities for a variety of reasons
it is it is slipping down this is an
article showing that you know
kindergarten vaccination rates have been
dropping especially uh it's starting
2019 but post covet it's still very high
it's in the high 90s but it's gone from
like 95 to 93 percent and what I think
the science shows about vaccines is that
these numbers you know we don't really
know what the threshold is but once you
start getting below 90 and 85 then
that's when you know as a parent of
young children I start to get you know
pretty nervous uh that we're going to
have outbreaks can I answer you yes
okay number one
you have to check in those outbreaks to
see whether the fact whether the the uh
the kids who are getting the measles are
actually unvaccinated and what strain it
is for example in the Disneyland strain
we know that it leaves 36 percent
other kids who got measles were vaccine
strained measles what we're seeing is
the vaccine waves and after 20 years
there's extreme lightning
oh the vaccine has not been around that
long and when the the the the the
uh generation that got fat that got
measles like myself dies off
you're going to see a lot of me return
to measles now I'm
measles mortality used to be tremendous
to our country oh it used to kill tens
of thousands of children a year
prior to 1964 prior to the introduction
the vaccine that mortality dropped off I
think the year the vaccine it was down
to about two or three hundred people a
year almost all those children were
Mountaineers the deaths from measles
so the death from these were declining
anyway and there's a study that the CDC
did in 2000 called and it's I and it was
published in I think uh Pediatrics and
they did it with Johns Hopkins
and they asked the question did vaccines
contribute to this dramatic decrease in
mortalities among American children that
have an after in the 20th century
and after looking at all the data they
came back and said no the vaccine said
almost nothing to do with it what what
what was responsible for those decline
immortalities was engineering Solutions
it was better Nutrition a coordinated
water
hygiene good food Etc and lower density
housing so
um
now then there's the other question
is it beneficial to get measles on your
kid is that beneficial and I uh I speak
as a survivor of measles and chickenpox
and diseases that no longer exist and me
too so you know for example
in Europe they don't allow the
chickenpox vaccine we make it here and
why don't they allow it because if you
give the kids a chicken pox vaccine
you're much more likely
to get on uh shingles when you're older
and we now have you have the vaccine
absolutely exactly wrong right it's like
if you have the chickenpox as a child
you're more likely to get shingles or
the vaccine
if you get if you if we have wild
chickenpox what the wild Chicken Box did
is every two years it would come back
and if you were if you got it when you
were a kid when it came back it was it
functioned as a booster so if you would
never get shingles
the people who used to get shingles were
people who were isolated from children
so they attended when I was young it
shingles was associated with old
curmudgeons who never went near kids
if you were near kids and you got that
exposure you wouldn't get shingles so
now that we've eliminated that annual
annual booster that people got I mean
now if it shingles epidemic and you know
the CDC did a study in fact a scientist
they did an extensive five or ten year
study
in Antelope Valley California by a
scientists that they had an NIH Sciences
contract scientist called Gary Goldman
and he predicted he said if you do this
vaccine this Mass vaccination we are
going to have massive shingle epidemic
in 10 years and that's exactly what
happened if you go on NHS website today
the National Health Service
in England it will say on that website
on the home page we do not
um mandate the chickenpox vaccine
because it causes shingles epidemics now
with measles
well there are lots and lots of studies
out there that so if you got measles as
a kid you're much you are you have a
heightened immunity
against certain kinds of cancers against
ectopic disease against cardiac disease
and Allergic Disease when you get older
so having those childhood diseases which
were essentially rashes in many cases
you um and we're you know self-limiting
and and harmless and to almost all
children
you it immunizes you and it builds your
immune response in the future against
all kinds of really bad disease that
actually kill you
there's also uh you know uh real risks
of uh you know bad outcomes for all
these diseases whether they are measles
mumps and rubella and you know it is
hard to look at charts like the one I
put up before or this one that has to do
with polio that has a similar story 1955
I have marked here is where the vaccine
was licensed polio plummets we know
polio and even more severe disease that
uh I would hope none of us would want to
see come back and so I guess first I'll
just ask you you know are you worried
about something like polio and then
secondly what is what would be your
policy approach to these vaccines would
you actually
allow people to continue getting the
people who want the vaccines to still
get them or would you ban some of these
vaccines outright
no I would yeah I'm not I wouldn't I
won't mandate vaccines if anybody wants
to get a vaccine you should get it
what I'll do is I'll make sure we have
good science that's all and then let
people make up their own minds and by
the way eighty percent of the polio
cases on Earth today according to the
who are vaccines trained polio that
means people got it from vaccinated
people can I uh just to draw them
because I think those cases are
extremely low uh as you can see by this
chart so if it's 80 it's 80 it's a very
small number worldwide polio is almost
eradicated so just you know
it is eradicated in the United States
but it's not eradicated around the world
and as I said the who is it is a killer
around the world
and according to WHL 80 of it is vaccine
strain can I ask that you would make
sure the science is solid what would uh
like uh what would be your method for
doing that I I
um saw a recent report from Anna merlon
from the uh from Vice who uh watched
your recent Health policy Summit I
couldn't find the the recording to
review myself so this is her reporting
she said that you would be actually you
said you would be actually issuing
executive orders from the Oval Office to
kind of shape Health policy and also
kind of Target medical journals that you
felt had uh I don't know been captured
is that an accurate characterization to
your yeah what you approach would be uh
to health policy from the Oval Office
yeah my my Approach will be to appoint
good people
will I actually do safety signs there's
not one of the 72 vaccine doses now
mandated for American children that have
ever been through a placebo controls
relicensure
as outrageous every other medicine has
to go through a pre-licensing safety
studies the vaccines are the only ones
that are exempt
and we're mandating them for healthy
children and all I'm saying is
let's do a real safety study so that we
know the risk profile on these products
we know what the benefits are and then
give people the real you know the real
information and we can't do that today
because we do not have
the same thing why are we giving
rotavirus vaccines how many lives do
those say can I ask can I ask
with if you know in a RFK FDA uh drugs
now currently you know cost a billion to
two billion dollars to bring to Market a
decade or more would drug approval be
easier or harder and what has been the
role of pharmaceuticals in increasing
health and lifespan over the past 50
years
of pharmaceutical drugs I mean again the
only thing the only studies that we have
on that or the McKinley and McKinley's
in 77 and the two well what what an FDA
would would your FDA
let me answer that question
uh Peter Gosha who's the founder of the
Cochran collaboration which is the most
prestigious group of independent
scientists 30 000 scientists who review
clinical data for the pharmaceutical
industry
um has done it recently issued a report
that show that uh pharmaceutical drugs
are now the third biggest killer in
America after
um after heart attacks and cancer
so no I do not intend to make it easier
to get drugs to Market I I think that
drugs should have drugs that are
on that have a uh have a some special uh
with their you know situation where
there's people dying that they should be
made available to them
but no I don't I what I think we should
be doing is looking at public health and
we should be looking at all forms of of
helping public health and boosting
people's immune systems not just
pharmaceutical products and not just
pharmaceutical Solutions we we now have
because of the way that things are done
in this country
because of the corruption of these
agencies we now have the sickest
population on Earth we have the highest
chronic disease rate of any country
why is it that we had 16 of the coveted
deaths in this country we only have four
percent of the world population it's
because our people are so sick and we've
done such a miserable job
at building Public Health you know we
pay more for medicine than any country
in the world we use more of it and
Americans with the sick as we're 79th in
the world in terms of health outcome
we're behind Mongolia behind Cuba we are
not doing it right we need intervention
and we need people to come in with a new
way of doing things in those agencies
and to be to be clear just to follow to
get an answer to that earlier question
you would be using your executive power
executive orders to accomplish that goal
to make it harder for certain drugs to
make it to Market or certain advice
I didn't say that what I said I want
good science
that show that these drugs actually work
and not the kind of corrupt trials that
we've had today okay well you did say
that it would be harder to bring drugs
to Market yeah
you know in some cases it may be harder
to bring up the market I don't think let
me let me go back and say I don't intend
to make it more difficult for you to
bring them to Market I think
um some of them I I do think that we
need to look at the fast track approval
process because it doesn't make any
sense to me that 50 almost 50 percent of
fda's budget is now coming from the
pharmaceutical industry
unless we can figure out a way to do
that that does not corrupt the public
officials who are supposed to be
regulating our drugs
I think
could you explain the the previous
comments about using the justice
department to go after medical journals
um what what did you mean by that
oh the medical journals are trusted by
doctors oh they're relied upon by
doctors for treatment regiments and
treatment protocols
the medical journals are virtually all
utterly corrupt right now and it's not
just me who's saying that it's Marsha
Engel who's with the long-term I think
two or three decades of New England
Journal of Medicine who says that they
become
propaganda festivals for the
pharmaceutical industry Richard Horton
who's the editor of the Lancet who
acknowledges that most of the stuff that
you read in the journals is not is wrong
it is fake science
and the journalist evolved to that point
because they're getting their money from
the pharmaceutical industry they're
getting you know 85 percent for
advertising and re and pre-prints or
reprints
um and those reprints are used by their
representatives to go to the doctor's
office and sell these drugs and so they
do an article that they know is they
they know it's false like for vioxx and
they end up killing 500 000 between 120
000 and 500 000 people
because they don't show in that document
that this drug that is now being used to
treat arthritis and headaches also kills
people from heart attacks so the doctors
don't know that who are prescribing it
they said the same thing with oxycodone
and now we've got a hundred and ten
thousand kids dying in this country
every year because FDA and the journals
elaborated with the pharmaceutical
industry to lie to the public and say
that oxycodone was not addictive and so
the doctors believe that journal article
and prescribe it to their patient and
they kill them and that's not the app
the opioid epidemic or rather the
epidemic of Overdose as though is
obviously beyond anything to do with
Oxycontin prescriptions peaked a decade
ago and and overdoses continue to
persist so we got something all right we
got a generation addicted to opioids
okay and when we cut back on the opioids
you know now they're they're getting
Chinese then and all that's coming
through Mexico
can I can I ask because we're we're a
bad out of time but you know one of one
of the critiques of your candidacy or
even your public profile is that you
traffic routinely and conspiracies and
it kind of conspiracist mindset where
almost everything that you know we take
for granted is bad so it's that you know
the covet vaccines you know not only
don't work but they're they're more
dangerous than covet itself 5G and Wi-Fi
are controlling you know controlling our
mind uh the government you know aspects
of the government that are supposed to
be in favor trying to help people
actually into hurting them uh AIDS is
not you know primarily caused by HIV or
HIV is not involved in AIDS atrazine is
changing frog sexuality and by
implications human sexuality your cousin
uh is not uh your cousin Michael skakel
is not guilty of the murder of Martha
Moxley that he was found guilty of
um you know the 2000 0004 election in
Ohio was stolen it kind of goes on and
on do you how do you how do you answer
people who say you know like this is the
sign of somebody who's thinking is
fundamentally
conspiracy-minded rather than kind of
dealing with brute reality you know that
is difficult and on you know and
terrible uh but is not what you seem to
be making of it well you know you did
something very unfair which is you made
a series of characterizations of my
belief many ways of my beliefs that
you've read in the newspapers
many of which are just wrong so you know
which which one well I mean go through
let's go through one at a time and I'll
tell you you know what I said and what I
believe
okay and usually HIV is not the primary
uh dry you know underlying condition in
AIDS is it's not a necessary condition
for AIDS right well
that is not controversial first of all I
say in my book I believe HIV causes AIDS
okay all right thanks that stack that
off the table then yeah now are there
AIDS cases
are there are there tens of thousands of
AIDS cases that do not have HIV that are
not HIV yeah that's not controversial
everybody knows that are there people
who have HIV and never get AIDS yes do
you do you understand though when I'm
saying and you know and this is your
opportunity to speak to people who are
like well you are a conspiracy theorist
and that that defines your your thinking
processes you know how do you how do you
respond to that because in a lot of ways
and I say this not to you know in a got
you but part of what Donald Trump you
know part of Donald Trump's successful
message was to say that the system is
not working the system is actually
designed to keep you down to at least
the percentage of the population you
seem to be channeling a similar energy
how do you convince people that you are
not just okay well you know first it was
vaccines you know then it was the 2004
election that was stolen in in the state
of Ohio and you've written that I don't
think I am you know contradicting
anything that you've said uh you know
and there are other examples of this
type of stuff how do you how do you how
do you speak to people who think that
you are just a conspiracy uh show me
where I got it wrong I mean I you know I
yes I'm willing to uh question public
narratives I've I've been taught to do
that my whole life my father taught me
to do that my father said to me
people in Authority lie and you know
that our obligation as Citizens and
democracy is to support our government
but also to be skeptical is there a
conspiracy or not a conspiracy is there
a major belief that you had over the
past 20 years that you have reversed
your opinion on or you're like oh I
actually did get that wrong
well show me where I got it wrong show
me show me what I got wrong okay
I mean my cousin Michael skakel after I
wrote my book
and found the two men who actually
killed Martha Moxley
and he interviewed them he was as a
result released from prison
did did I mean Rolling Stone has
retracted two of your stories I mean is
it is rolling stone okay that is not
true
Rolling Stone retracting one of my
stories
15 years after we're after and during
the pandemic they retracted a one story
that I did on Arizona vaccines
they never shown and and rolling stone
at that time had changed ownership okay
it was part of the Orthodoxy but they
were never able to show a single mistake
and nobody has shown one single mistake
that I made in that article Salon didn't
show it it's a lawn corrected four
errors and Joan Wallace the editor wrote
me a letter and apologized for her
editors having made those errors I
didn't make any of the errors show me an
error that I made
um I will say now uh let what is your
final pitch because this I think this
helps explain your appeal uh in general
that you know we live in a we live in a
society where yes we recognize that you
know our leaders lie all the time you
know and that's political leaders it's
Business Leaders it's religious leaders
um you know uh and you know so there's a
general lack of faith and confidence and
Trust in institutions how do you how do
you address that and how do you
um you know what it what is the pitch
then to Libertarians
well I mean by you know by your criteria
virtually every libertarian is a
conspiracy theorist now a lot of them
are a lot of them are I many of my best
friends are
yeah I mean if your quest question
government narratives that is our you
know we're supposed to
supposed to have a title
conversation and we're supposed to you
know be skeptical about aggregations of
power
oh you know and I'm that way but I also
you know will tell you this
if somebody shows me a fact that I got
wrong I'm gonna change my opinion I'm
not going to dig in and you know I get
facts wrong you know at times you know I
we I publish a lot
my uh my book was 200 almost 250 000
words and 2200 footnotes and today you
know I ask at the beginning if you if
you find a mistake and you tell me and
we're gonna correct it well let me ask
you that one very specific fact then uh
that I can demonstrate whether this is
right or wrong do you think that the
covid vaccine which we're in agreement
should not have been mandated across
Society for all ages regardless of
circumstance but do you believe that on
net it saved lives that it prevented
people from dying of covid I think that
I mean according to its own you know the
Pfizer clinical trial data
the vaccine saves one life for every 22
000 vaccines administered from covet one
life
and if hey and it takes four lives from
cardiac arrest so and then you know so
that's one data point we I have a whole
book of data points that that called I
called died suddenly
it shows all of them the massive data
points that indicate that the magazine
actually uh cause more problems than it
averted so and I'll just give you this
one data point to listen to to think
about
and this isn't just positive but there's
many of them there are many that I think
are
we are one of the most vaccinated
coveted vaccinated countries in the
world and we had the highest death rate
in the world from covet
um
Haiti which had a one percent the 1.4
vaccination rate had a death rate one
two hundredth of our country Nigeria
which had a 1.3 vaccination rate
at a death rate 1 200 of our country on
all if you look at the and look at
Nation by nation and go through the
Johns Hopkins data
which is all graphed in the first page
or oh you'll show that the real deaths
came following vaccination the xss and
that's exactly what the Pfizer clinical
trial predicted happened yeah I will say
that you know comparing across countries
like this you have to take into account
things like demographics age health
status so it's extremely hard to do that
what we can say is you know I'll just
pull up this is the covid weekly death
rate by vaccination status all ages in
the U.S that orange line at the top
shows unvaccinated compared to
vaccinated and vaccinated with booster
and um I mean it's hard to dispute that
a lot of people who would have otherwise
died from covid looking at that probably
lived because of the vaccine so again
you've got your book you've got your
footnotes we've got uh some slides we
pulled up today we've got uh notes to
sources and people can you know sort
these things out but I just you know
want to make the case that uh it's
possible to be critical of the way that
the government uh approached this and
kind of the heavy-handedness with which
some of the the covid vaccines were
mandated while accepting that um there
were some serious benefits as well and
and that's where where I stand with this
at the end of the day I'm happy to show
you graphs that show the opposite and
I'm happy to show you the public data
and that you know is generally
acknowledged now
that there was not a greater death rate
among the vaccinated than the uh the
greater death rate the higher death
rates were among the vaccinated and I'll
tell you one of the problem that graph
Perceptions in that graph is the way
they calculated
vaccinated because the way they
calculated it for that graph
is that they you were unvaccinated until
two weeks after
your second vaccine right because that's
when it has full protection kicked in
according to the CDC that's right but
but the big death rate if you look at
all the Johns Hopkins data the big death
rate from the vaccine and you know
because people were getting covered
right after getting vaccinated
and the big Death Race then were
happening immediately after the first
vaccine so those death rates were
counted among unvaccinated people even
though they were fully they were
vaccinated
and you're that's what your graph your
graph is picking up that artifact I was
actually picking up that the vaccines
cause excess deaths
all the vaccines
you know don't trust me go and look at
the graphs the Johns Hopkins grass died
suddenly and you will see that yes that
is true can I ask just as as a general
closing thought and I want to give you
the last uh word here in in a RFK
America would you know that which is not
mandatory is outlawed I mean like this
part of part of what we're struggling
with when we you know when we pull back
a little bit is that we seem to live in
a world now where either something is
mandatory or it is outlawed um and I
think a general libertarian perspective
is that what we want to do is give more
individuals more breathing room to
choose how to live to you know have more
autonomy in how they go about their
daily business and you know you know
what is your pitch to deliver that kind
of world I guess well I mean I think
that's what I've been saying throughout
I don't know I implementation
it is not demanding things but give
people a choice you know if somebody
wants to get vaccinated
I have no problem with that I just don't
think you should mandate it and
particularly for a product that has you
know that that has no insurance policy
and that carries over into a wide array
of policy areas and things like that I
believe in Freedom of Choice
unless it's going to hurt your neighbor
or you know it's going to hurt the
commons you know people should be able
to do what they want with as much
Freedom as possible and the government
should not be on any
okay I think that's a uh a point worth
uh ending on thank you uh for your time
and for the conversation Robert F
Kennedy Jr
thanks for having me give me your
address and I'll send you the book
okay we got it thank you I have the book
I appreciate